[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANJU DEVADAS: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Manju
Devadas, and today I'll
be talking along with Cisco
about how AI enables enterprise
digital transformation, along
with deeper customer insight.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
So shortly, I'll be introducing
some of my co-speakers, Sanjiv
Patel and Vikram,
and together we
will be talking about how
AI enables enterprises
with digital transformation
and deeper customer insight.
Before that, let me
give you a little bit
of background about myself.
I'm Manju Devadas.
I have worked for 17 years
in predictive analytics.
As technology has evolved, as
computation and memory gets
cheaper, the power of
technology now used
in analytics and
decision making has now
started to change
transformation,
and now has started to
transform businesses
in ways that now
has been classified
as the fourth
Industrial Revolution.
But myself and my
co-speakers will
try to give you
enough insight so
that you can see why the
industry looks at it that way
with some real-life
enterprise examples.
So quick introduction
about Pluto7.
We are Google's
preferred partner
when it comes to machine
learning and AI expertise.
It's not just about technology.
It's also understanding business
and driving business to change.
That's the transformation
in the retail supply
chain and manufacturing.
That's how the joint partnership
between Google and Pluto7
is helping many customers.
Before we go into
machine learning and AI,
I'm sure a lot of
you are reading
about machine learning and
AI, whether it's magazine,
television, and so on.
We are now talking with
Google on Google's platform.
Everything that Google does
is machine learning and AI,
be it Gmail, your YouTube,
your Photos, and so on.
Now, what does
that mean when you
apply in an enterprise context?
Let's try to simplify
it a bit, right?
So if you look at simple
decision making that
happens in a human brain, it's
really three simple things
that happen.
You gather information.
You process the information.
You make a judgment.
The way you make a
judgment about weather,
what day it is,
what should I wear,
is no different from a
process point of view
in terms of how you make a
decision in an enterprise.
Remember, it's the
same human being.
What decisions you make at
home and what decisions you
make in enterprise,
whether you talk
in the context of
mimicking the brain's
decision-making process,
it's very similar, right?
So now, AI and machine
learning is really
mimicking that
decision-making process.
Now, when it comes to humans,
we are biological creatures.
So we have our
limitations in terms
of how we make decisions, our
objectivity, and over a period
of time, as we gain experience
in our business or career,
we build biases,
be it about demand
planning, forecasting,
supply planning,
knowing our
customers' experience.
We build our belief--
what's a good
market to go after?
What's not a good market?
What's a product that
is profitable or not?
And then we have
our personal biases.
In my industry experience
working with many customers--
including Cisco, whom we will
be listening to very soon--
as a company, we have served
companies like GE, Apple,
Target, and many, many more.
In my career, about 30
companies [INAUDIBLE]
that I've helped with
business transformation,
especially around
forecast accuracy,
I've found that 30%
of forecast accuracy
is pretty common in
certain industries.
And if you think about it-- and
when I really look at why that
happens--
it's got a lot to
do with human bias.
And now, when you
try to start looking
at the same thing from a machine
learning and AI standpoint,
we are talking about, still,
the same time series modeling.
And with that, how you
make your decision, how
do you project what the weather
is going to be at what accuracy
level, is the same
methodology or approach
that you take when it comes
to making business decision.
If they're making a time series
decision, which is commonly
understood as
regression analysis,
you are applying those
decisions around how much you're
going to sell, which
customer is interacting
with you on your website,
and so on, what's
the propensity to buy, a lot
of these kind of decisions.
Now you take the data
and you blend that
with your own ideologies,
beliefs, emotions, and logic,
and you come to conclusion.
However, when it comes to
machine learning and AI,
we try to keep
those biases away.
Biases still play a role
because data sometimes
has embedded biases in them.
However, what we do here
with machine learning and AI,
we try to help enterprise
make more and more decisions
through objective
data pattern analysis.
That's the power of
machine learning and AI.
Now, in my experience,
I've worked
with various customers that want
to automate their factories.
They're looking at human
traffic movement and [INAUDIBLE]
including health devices
and medical devices,
human medical
analysis and so on.
In this variety of
industry that we sell,
one thing that is common is
data silos and complexity
of decision making and
volumes of decision making.
These are pretty common themes.
And when you look at
this as the larger
the enterprise that
you get, many of you
can relate that these
data silos sometimes
create its own challenges
in your decision making.
And when you do it
at scale, now we
have to structure your
organizations differently,
how people interact differently
amongst them and so on.
All of this in the current
world when we look at--
I deal with a lot of
retail companies--
that when you look at the bottom
line KPIs and look at what's
really happening in the
business, this could lead to--
whether it's for forecasting, or
access, or shortage of supply,
are really not--
even though they
have a lot of data--
not really understanding
the customer well enough.
We are living in the world of
e-commerce, digital commerce,
where companies like Amazon,
Walmart.com, Flipkart,
or Baidu, and many, many
more around the world
are now talking about
real-time knowing
your customer, real-time
analysis, real-time sentiment
analysis.
You take the same
learnings and apply
that in your
enterprise context, you
will now have the
same power when
it comes to machine learning and
AI on a Google Cloud Platform.
I run a lot of C-level executive
workshops and presentations,
helping them transform
their business.
Some of the common
questions that we get asked
is, hey, we hear about
machine learning and AI,
but how do I use that
to understand or engage
my customers better?
What's the magic behind it?
Does it really help
my efficiencies go up?
So there are lot of
questions in their mind.
It's really about
this paradigm shift.
If you let humans make
decisions-- of course,
humans use a lot of
softwares and so on--
but it may have proven that
you have 60% to 80% accuracy.
Now you look at
shifting your KPIs,
whether it's your sales
performance or marketing
performance or supply
chain performance
to get to an accuracy that
could not be imagined possible.
And sometimes when we walk
into a customer site to say,
we have all kinds
of software, now
what's really a big deal
with machine learning and AI?
To give you an analogy, if I
asked this person on the left
to carry 2,000 bricks
and go up that building
and put it in one hour, he
would say, you are crazy.
I'm not going to be
able to carry that.
But with a crane you don't
think that's a big deal.
When it comes to
decision making,
simple decision making
in an enterprise--
it could be around processing
invoice or it could be around
deciding which customer to
run an email campaign on--
when you do it through
traditional means,
you'll run into
limitations on the left.
You really need to now think
about scale on the right.
Even if I say 10,000
bricks, it doesn't matter.
As in, that's the
power that you get.
That's the paradigm shift.
Now again, it's easy for
me to show you an analogy.
But when it comes
to enterprises,
you have to think about how this
machine learning gets embedded
in different parts doing
simple tasks initially
so that humans can trust
and interact and depend,
whether it's a recommendation
for upselll, cross-sell
or a recommendation to focus
on certain set of customers.
You have to make it
part of your business.
When we walk into
a customer site,
sometimes innovation and machine
learning goes hand-in-hand,
and our customers
ask, hey, how can I
use machine learning and AI?
So we have run into scenarios
after scenarios where
we improve the taste of beer.
[INAUDIBLE] for one of the
largest beer manufacturers
in the world.
Now that sounds magical.
But if you look at
the story behind that,
it is really crunching
massive amount of data.
Crunching the data, analyzing,
and coming up with patterns.
Similarly, when you beat
forecast accuracy by 20%,
it looks magical.
[INAUDIBLE] hard to believe, but
once you double click and show
how you do it, now you
know that you've really
started the journey
of machine learning
and AI, the new paradigm.
Things like people get amazed,
how does Amazon deliver exactly
on the same day when they say?
And Walmart, and so on.
The same kind of
capability now you
can enable in your
ecosystem, your enterprise.
Now that requires, of course,
the innovative thinking.
Then comes when you know
your customers better,
when you are able to
understand the sentiments
and analyze that
better, how can you
help the customer better
through price adjustments?
These are different
innovations that our customers
are thinking and acting on.
We have picked three of the
most common scenarios here.
Customer engagement--
we'll talk a lot
about that, along with Cisco.
And they have some very
fascinating story as well as
some great speakers coming up.
Now, along with
that, when you look
at problems like
forecast accuracy
or preventive maintenance,
it's really up to you
how far can you imagine
within your ecosystem.
Take the most mundane
task and translate that
into an ML model.
Understand this journey.
And to drive home
this point, today we
are going to focus on
customer engagement
and really understand, what
does it mean to understand
your customers better?
How are your
customers interacting?
You hear this
story really often.
Data is the new oil.
If you believe in
that statement,
and if you think about how
Google internally operates,
Google has the most
amount of data,
practically, in the world.
And it's phenomenal how
Google search engine works.
It's all powered by
machine learning and AI
in various forms.
And now the same concepts can be
extended into your enterprise.
Think about how to use
the power of your data
in a centralized location
where you can mine the insights
and make decisions
on behalf of humans,
better than humans
in every regard.
This is not about
replacing humans.
This is about empowering and
making humans superhumans.
So in the retail
context, we are all
used to this getting
recommendations.
Hey, you might like this shirt,
or you might like this product.
So when you're watching
movies on Netflix--
you watched this, so
you might like that.
And in machine
learning language,
it's simple
classification problem,
and sometimes it's a
classification and a regression
problem solved using TensorFlow
hosted on Google Cloud
ML with your data
centralized in BigQuery.
I just rolled out a
simple solution for you
on this verbally.
It's really as simple as putting
those Lego blocks together.
With this kind of
simple architecture,
now you can think of practically
any amount of customer history
or reviews, sentiments,
whether it's online reviews
or what they're saying on
Twitter or social media.
You can centralize
that without worrying
about scale and capacity.
When you start thinking about
centralizing your information
and now making your
organization think differently,
what's important
for you to realize
is that this is not
a one-time project.
It's a journey.
And pretty soon you'll will
be listening from Sanjiv.
The journey between myself
and Sanjiv and Vikram
started, really, with
the conversation around,
why do you need to worry
about all this infrastructure?
Why not centralize
the data, at least
for your specific
business problems?
And let's start it there.
With something as simple
as that, to see them evolve
is amazing.
Cisco is a fantastic company
with all kinds of complexity.
And when you start getting
into this kind of journey,
it's very important that one,
you select the right platform.
Two, you blend the domain
knowledge and expertise
to really take the
machine learning
and put it into practical use.
This is not a sci-fi project
anymore for enterprises.
And with all the experience
that we have gained
and we continue to gain around
the world, what we are going
to see in the next
decade is bigger
than the internet revolution.
With that, I'm proud to bring on
stage Cisco, who will walk you
through their journey.
And please welcome Sanjiv Patel,
who leads the data sciences
organization, as well as Vikram,
who leads the machine learning
and AI practice at Cisco.
Sanjiv, Vikram.
SANJIV PATEL: Thanks, Manju.
It's great to be here.
As Manju said, I'm Sanjiv Patel.
I lead the data
science group that
focused on the customer,
partner, and sales experience.
VIKRAM VERMA: And I am Vikram.
I am technical lead for
this particular program.
SANJIV PATEL: So
today, I'm going
to talk to you
about Omni-Channel
and some of the
challenges that we've had
and how we've worked
through those.
And so I'll take you
back to a few years ago
when Vikram and I were
thinking about ways
to get our new customer
success organization started.
And what we noted is that in
starting the customer success
organization, we were
opening up many new channels.
And the challenge
that we were having
is that these
channels were often
disjointed from the other
channels that we had.
And it potentially
lead to is customers
could engage with
certain channels
and do that in a way
that was completely
separate from their
experience in another channel.
And what we recognized
is that we really
needed to tie the
experience together
from these different channels.
Now, I'm guessing Cisco
isn't alone there, right?
That's probably a
pretty common experience
in most B2B companies because
B2B companies are traditionally
not focused on this
aspect as much.
And as the number of channels
has exploded over recent years
and the desire to connect
those channels has increased,
as well as the
desire of customers
to have more of a B2C experience
in all of their interactions
has increased, it's
put a lot of pressure
on companies to change.
And so we recognized
that we needed
to do something that
would allow us to bring
the experience
together in some way,
and so that regardless
of the channel
the customer chose to
engage with us through,
they would have a consistent
and personalized experience.
What we really
wanted to make sure
took place is that
when a customer used
a certain channel,
that channel was
able to interact with the
customer in a way that
considered all of the
other interactions
that that customer
had had with Cisco
and brought the most
amount of information
back into that
engagement so that it
was an intelligent,
personalized experience.
And that leads me to a couple
of quotes that are, I think,
very relevant.
One, talking about how important
that customer experience
has gotten to the
point where it is even
maybe more important
than product and price
as a differentiator.
The other one being
that AI is playing
a bigger and bigger role
in the customer experience.
And that's certainly
something that Vikram and I
felt was the case when
we started this journey.
And we knew that we
needed to build something
based on an AI foundation.
So that's what we want
to share with you today.
First, let me describe
some of the challenges
that we had as we were looking
at the problem statement.
So first, as I've
mentioned already,
we had a desire to have an
Omni-Channel experience that
was connected, but we saw that
there were certain silos--
not everything was fragmented--
but there were certain silos
that we needed to figure out.
How do we pull those back in as
part of an overall experience?
And by the way, that includes
not only just digital channels,
but it also includes
sales channels,
people who are
engaging with customers
and making sure that
those people have
the same type of interaction
and that's consistent.
The other one was siloed
campaign execution.
And what I mean
here is that as we
would bring a
channel online, there
would be a team of people
working to enable it.
But sometimes they didn't have
the right information from what
was going on in other channels
and they were optimizing
for that particular channel.
So that led to a
siloed approach.
And that also led to a lot
of labor-intensive efforts.
As people would try
to ramp up a channel,
they would try to gather
data independently
from other channels and
bring that together.
So as channels grew
linearly, we almost
found that the
number of people that
were involved in
supporting those channels
grew exponentially.
And we wanted to
figure out a way
that we could
address that issue.
A core part of the issue for us
was the scattered data issue.
We weren't pulling
all of this data
from these different
channel interactions
as well as new
data that we wanted
to include, such as customer
interactions and our products,
together in a way that
could support the customer
experience.
And as a result, we didn't
have the amount of insights
that we wanted to, and we
felt like we could do more
around the intelligence,
around those interactions
to make them more
useful to customers
and improve their experience.
So what we recognized,
as I mentioned,
is we can't do this if we're
going to build it effectively
through just human
decision making.
It was too complex given the
portfolio that Cisco has,
the size of the
company, the diversity
of the types of customers,
and their expectations
around the experience
that they would get.
And so purely human
decision making
was not going to
solve the problem.
And what we felt
like we really needed
was a strategy that
allowed us to have
a path to something scalable.
And so there were three
pillars of that strategy--
connected data, connected
intelligence, and then
automation.
And so I'll give you examples
of each one of those in turn
so you have a sense of
what we're talking about.
So the first one is around
connecting data and getting it.
And that's a pretty
obvious point
that it's important to get data.
However, part of what
I want to talk about
is the way we were gathering
data and connecting it,
which I think is
the important part.
And it's where the machine
learning piece really relates.
So we were inspired by some
examples in the industry
where they were using machine
learning to connect data.
One of the ones that I
very specifically remember
is around hospitals.
So hospitals do a good job
connecting data together
using machine learning.
It's not possible for them to
match purely on Social Security
numbers.
Sometimes people make up
Social Security numbers.
It's not possible to match
on just patient names.
Sometimes those
names are identical.
And so they use machine
learning as a way
to make sure that the
highest likelihood
match is taking place.
And they can do that
very fast and scalably.
Well, similarly, we decided
to use that approach
in connecting some of our
customer data together.
And so whether it was connecting
contacts back to accounts,
whether it was actually
connecting different channel
data together from
different groups that
didn't traditionally
fit together very well
or even doing kind of
operational matching of data,
we started to really
embrace this approach
of connecting data.
And what we found is that
it was three big advantages.
One is it was much
more accurate.
This chart gives
you a sense of some
of the accuracy that we
found when we were comparing
the human-based approach to
the machine-learning-based
approach.
It was also much more fast.
So we were able
to do this quickly
within a matter of
days, as opposed
to taking a lot
longer than that.
And it was very
flexible to change.
So as data changed, which
changes pretty much constantly,
you didn't have to go back
through a human process
to figure out how to
deal with that change.
You were actually able to adapt
to that change very quickly.
And so these are
all big advantages.
And the connecting
the data became
foundational to the intelligence
work that we wanted to do.
The other thing that we
spent a lot of time doing
is around understanding intent.
And so I think--
we're here at Google.
Google does that really well
with their search engine.
If you go in and you type
in the letters C-A-L, CAL,
into the Google
search engine, Google
knows that you're looking for
the University of California
at Berkeley, which is not
intuitive to people who are
outside of the United States.
And the reason they know that
is because millions of searches
has been done in which
intent has been established.
Well, similarly, we
started looking at problems
that we could apply a
similar type of logic to.
And there were many of them.
One of them is the
fact that at Cisco, we
have a broad
portfolio of products,
and we tend to sell solutions
to business customers.
And those solutions are not
just one specific product.
They tend to be groups of
products all sold together.
And one of our problems
was establishing,
when has a solution been
sold to a customer that
is the same for two
different customers,
meaning customer A may have
bought products A, B, C, and D.
Customer B may have bought
products E, F, G, and H.
But they may be
the same solution.
And so how do we match those
two as the same solution?
So what we did is we looked at
five million deals in which we
looked at what
customers had purchased,
and we started looking at the
groupings of those products,
not just what was purchased.
But then what do multiple
people purchase when
they're purchasing from Cisco?
And how do they group together?
And we were able to use that
in a number of different ways.
First, the grouping became
an input into things
like our models.
It also became a good
thing to augment feedback
from product managers
who were telling us how
to look at solutions at Cisco.
And we were able to use it in a
number of other things as well.
But this became some
foundational work
we could do from a data
side in preparation
for the next step, which
was the intelligence piece.
Next, I want to talk about
the scalable intelligence.
And what I'm going to go
into is the AI and machine
learning aspect of things.
The thing that I want
to emphasize here
is that there's two
strategies that we had.
One was around inbound.
So when customers
come to us, we want
a way to classify what
their interest is.
And we want a way to respond to
it as automatically as possible
and as intelligently
as possible,
taking into account all the
information that we have
about them through things
like a chatbot or something
like those types of mechanisms.
We also, however, wanted
to be able to route
those inbound
interactions to people.
So if there are people
who should be involved,
we want the ability to do the
routing to the right person.
And then we want
the person to be
enabled with the right
set of priorities
around how to respond
to those and what
to say in the interactions to
be as successful as possible.
So that's how we're thinking
about our inbound AI vision,
if you will.
From an outbound
perspective, we want
to be able to make sure that
when we're pushing out things
like emails to customers,
we want to make sure
that it's part of a journey.
What we want to be able
to do is increasingly
make that a data-science-driven
journey, meaning
that we are determining the
right content, the right timing
for that content, and the right
to positioning in that content
so that the customer ultimately
is getting what they want.
And we are making
sure that we're
engaging with that
customer in a manner that
makes sense for them,
as opposed to it's
a generic journey for us.
And so this development of
data-science-driven journeys
is something that we're still
working on and in the process
of doing.
So let me share a couple
of examples with you
around sort of some of the
things we're doing around AI
and machine learning that
I think may be interesting.
The first one is around Amazon.
And Amazon predicts
shopper interest
based on their behavior.
And this is very well known.
Everybody knows that
Amazon does this.
What I found interesting
is that Amazon, Airbnb,
and many different
companies, Spotify,
all describe how
much of their revenue
is actually based on their
recommendation engine.
And that's, I think,
a fascinating thing
in terms of how
important these are.
So we built a recommendation
engine as well,
looking at historical
product, purchasing behavior,
and what customers had
in their installed base.
And the thing that stands
out to me, in addition
to the ROI of the
model, is just how many
different places it's been
deployed across Cisco.
And so from emails, to display
ads, to online, even to sales
recommendations, we were using
it in a broad variety of ways
so that we can get as much
leverage out of it as possible
and think about what
the importance of that
is in terms of a consistent
customer experience.
Now you have
numerous channels all
having conversations
with the customers,
and having similar upsell
conversations and that sort
of thing with customers.
It's a great way to
drive consistency.
The other example is, and
I'll use Google again,
Google uses Google Maps and can
provide optimal routes for you.
This optimization
piece, well, that's
a big piece of what we want
to be able to do as well.
And so one of the
things that we have done
is look at how we can
use machine learning
and AI to predict what
the best channel to engage
a customer is going to be.
And so I mentioned
that a little bit
earlier in the inbound and
outbound visions of how we
were building our AI roadmap.
And so, in this case, we were
scoring in customer engagement
through a variety of
different channels
and effectively
predicting how we should
be engaging with that customer.
So for example, in this
case, if the customer
has a very high email score,
great, we'll use email.
But if it's a low email score
and something else is bigger,
well, we probably won't
email that customer
because we know it's
going to be effectively
not valuable for that customer
and seek to engage them
through other means.
The last thing I want to
talk about is automation.
And automation is, I
think, probably the hardest
piece of this, which is, how
do you take those insights
and how do you put them into
these different channels
so that they work?
And so I'll describe at a high
level our approach to this.
Effectively, what
we're doing is we
have a group piloting
as new channels are
onboarded-- piloting
the use of these models.
And then we have a group
that's operationalizing that.
So I'll talk about that
for just a brief moment.
We've got, effectively,
two groups.
And I found that this is a
really good practice for us.
We've got one group which is
a global business team that
seeks to work with
channel owners,
understand what they're
trying to accomplish,
has the understanding of
the models that we have
so they can bring it
to the channel owner
and give them options in
terms of how they might want
to engage with customers,
and then comes back to us
and provides sometimes
requests, sometimes ask
requests for support,
that sort of thing.
And so frequently, we use
things, even something
as basic as an
Excel spreadsheet,
just to get started
and understand
how we can serve the people
in that channel better.
Then we have a
deployment team that
is made up of data
engineers that's focused
on automating that piece.
So how do we get it in so
that these human beings
don't have to be involved
in all of the process?
That team that's working on the
automation is also working on,
how do we drive a regular
cadence of A/B testing
and experimentation
so we can make
the engagement in that
channel as robust as possible?
So with that, I will
hand it over to Vikram
to talk about some of the
ways that we're handling this
from an infrastructure
perspective.
VIKRAM VERMA: Thank you, Sanjiv.
And I will start with
Jeff Bezos's comment.
You said, AI is a horizontal
enabling layer and there is no
aspect of the business where
AI cannot add to value.
Now, going back to Sanjiv's
point about what we are doing
and how we are doing--
when Sanjiv and I started
to look at the vision
into technical aspect,
we started to lay down,
what does it mean from
a technical requirement
point of view?
We had hundreds of
thing, but I will just
highlight four of them.
First one was get more data.
Second one is build as
many models as we can.
Third one is double
down on our data points.
Some of the data points
that in B2B model
we have not looked at it,
like user behavior, user
interactions.
Some places we are
good in the company.
Some places we are not.
How do we make
that as a practice,
get that data to enable
the better working models
for our stakeholders?
And the fourth thing is not
only building the models,
giving it to the
users, but how do
we drive that personalization
that Sanjiv talked about,
a real dynamic
personalization where
we can integrate these
data science models
or these AI techniques like
[INAUDIBLE] and chatbot
like Sanjiv talked about
in our real-user experience
across the different channels?
We know that historically
we always used
to know where the customer was.
Now what we want to know is
where the customer will be
and what do we need to
suggest to that customer?
And if that customer is
taking a different action,
then dynamically change
that recommendation.
And by recommendation, it's not
only product recommendation,
its about what we
show them, what
we want to bring
to their attention,
and what actions
do we want to drive
based on those interactions.
So based on this
requirement, when
we looked at what do we
really need technically
to do those things, we
needed an environment
over our excellent
environment within Cisco,
which can scale for a lot of
data where the data [INAUDIBLE]
and integration is easier.
It is not too complicated.
We have a dynamic where we
can generate this data science
model and deploy
them effectively.
And third thing is, how
can we put a microservices
around this data science
environment which
can provide the concurrent
A/B test pre-built in it so
that this whole environment
could come together and help
our experience end to end?
This was a complicated ask.
We looked at multiple
windows, and then we
decided to go with
Google Cloud [INAUDIBLE]..
And we will continue to use
our internal environment
that we have.
But we are going to supplement
with this all trial experiment
that Sanjiv mentioned on
the Google environment
and bring those learning
back in our experience
how we interact
with our customers.
And when I say customer, it's
the real customers, our sellers
and other partners, all
the three dimensions.
If you look at our architecture
that we are working towards,
majority of these pieces
are already in place.
But like any other
company, we have
slow-moving, slow-changing data,
which we call the reference
information, and
fast-paced data which
is transactional structure.
And we had a lot of data
sources from our third party,
from our application.
We had even [INAUDIBLE].
So when we looked
at it, we've tried
to come up with
different strategy of how
to ingest these data
points within Google Cloud.
And we are using pub/sub.
We are using GCP
as a [INAUDIBLE]..
We are using the realtime
data transfer as well
and putting that
into Google so we
can build those scalable
models at a scale
and enable them through
micro services environment.
So as Sanjiv talked about,
we have implemented energy.
We are taking it
to Google Cloud.
We have all these data
sources, which we have already
moved to Google Cloud.
And we are working on Apache
[? B, ?] pretty much pub/sub,
to take these third-party events
and bring it to Google Cloud
so it can improve on our
data science capabilities
and enable that experience
that we just talked about.
If you are next generation
firewall [? ice ?] and customer
of Cisco, you can see
that difference even now.
We have already
taken the first step.
When you log into Cisco.com,
on those product pages,
you will see those
customizations.
And a lot of things
are coming in future
pretty soon as we are
moving on this journey.
With this, I would say there
are a lot of things that we did.
And some of the things in
the Google Cloud as a POC
which we did was
sentiment analysis
using Google's pre-built API.
Google provides an
environment where
we can analyze the phone call.
We can analyze user behavior.
We can analyze a sentiment
based on what we are getting
or the feedback from the user.
That provides us faster go
to market and a capability
where we can
personalize and meet
our objectives much faster.
With this, that
wraps our session.
Stay tuned for Q&A, and we
will be back in a minute.
Thank you.
MANJU DEVADAS: OK.
Thanks for listening
through the session so far.
You know, we see some
questions coming up,
and we'll take a few of them.
Between myself and Sanjiv, we'll
tag team along to answer these.
The first question is, do you
need a large amount of data
to run AI predictions and
recommendations model?
How can smaller businesses
and less customer data
benefit from such models?
As a general rule
of thumb, yes, the
larger the amount
of data, the better.
But there's no
definitive measure
on how much exactly you need.
It's a blend of
knowing your business.
It's a blend of what you are
trying to build in your model
and what kind of insights
you are trying to get.
And is there enough
pattern in the data?
So these are some three
or four key aspects
that you have to look at
before judging whether you
have enough data or not.
In my experience working with
various customers' workloads,
extremely large--
literally, like a fortune 10--
to the extremely small,
which is like SNB.
And interestingly, depending on
the business urgency and need,
both the spectrum of businesses
use machine learning.
And for example online
e-tailers, as they call,
online retailers, extremely
small business but extremely
fast in adopting machine
learning with streaming data
of customer reviews and so on.
Other spectrum, the
large enterprises,
also look for this because they
have a massive amount of data.
That's all I'll answer
for that question.
So Sanjiv, you want to
take the next question?
SANJIV PATEL: Yeah.
So the next question
is, what data elements
is Cisco looking for to
increase customer experience?
So I'd say two big things come
to mind, generally speaking.
So one is data that comes
from customer interactions.
I mean, that should
be pretty obvious.
But let's take WeChat,
which is getting
bigger and bigger in China.
So as we're engaging
with customers on WeChat,
we really should have
a way to make sure
that that data is
coming back into Cisco
and we're making sure that we're
doing something with that data,
with the thought that that data
should improve the experience
and engagement in
other channels.
So that's one side of things.
The other side of
things is actually
data from our products.
So we collect a huge amount of
data back from our products.
And increasingly, as we're
adding more and more products
to our portfolio, especially
in the software space,
that's growing.
So a big part of what
we're trying to do
is make sure that as
that data is coming back,
we can use that to
improve the experience
and to personalize it.
If we know, for
example, that customers
are trying to implement
certain features,
for example, then we should
be able to use that in a way
to help them so they can get
value from their products that
much faster.
MANJU DEVADAS: OK.
Thanks, Sanjiv.
So see the next question.
This has two, three parts to it.
How do we make
sure companies are
getting maximum revenue using
AI from a marketing perspective?
How to validate the results?
And how to make sure
you have the right data
while training the model?
This is a pretty
loaded question.
Between myself and
Sanjiv, we'll answer this.
First of all, ROI--
remember I mentioned early on
that machine learning and AI
projects are a journey
and not a project?
So keep that in mind.
If I told you 15 years back,
or rather, in 1995, internet
is going to change every
aspect of your enterprise
and the work, for
most enterprise
it would be pretty hard to
imagine how that would be.
And today, nobody debates that.
You have to keep that
kind of perspective
when you invest in
machine learning and AI.
Don't expect quick
returns or magic here.
There is no magic.
And it's a collective
learning of Google
and many similar companies
that is now available for you
to learn.
Now, when you build
machine learning models,
to validate the result, keep
one rule of thumb in mind.
You're mimicking
human decision making.
In other words,
humans already make
a lot of decisions
sitting at the desk.
If you take a business
problem or forecasting,
for example, how do you know
that the machine learning
is predicting better than you?
You train the models.
You evaluate the model.
During the evaluation
phase, check whether it
is doing better than humans.
Then you have your answer.
And there's-- as you go into
building machine learning
model, you'll understand
this even better.
And the last thing
is, how do you
make sure you have right data?
There is this
concept of clean data
that you hear very
often in enterprise.
And fundamentally, I don't
believe in clean data.
Data exist the way they are.
Imagine if Google
were to sit and clean
every single data
that gets entered.
They'll never be able
to get you the results.
With that perspective-- I'm not
saying don't clean the data.
Data appropriation
takes 60% to 70%
of time building
machine learning models.
What's much more important is
don't try to make it perfect.
Keep moving it along.
Let the model run.
Let the model also
tell you a few things
that you can improvise on.
Sanjiv, do you want
to add anything to it?
SANJIV PATEL: I totally
agree with your perspective,
actually, Manju.
That's correct.
MANJU DEVADAS: Great.
You want to take the next one?
SANJIV PATEL: Sure.
So the next question
is, will the models
that you're developing tell
the humans or virtual sales
in real time of who to target?
And how does it improve
conversion rate?
So another question that has
many different aspects to it.
I think what I'm honing in on
in is this word "real time."
So yes, the models will tell
human beings whom to target.
We are doing that already today.
The real time piece is the one
that we're working towards.
So for example, let's say the
best case scenario, Manju,
you know, you're a
customer of Cisco's.
And you come to Facebook.
And you go, hey, I want
to buy a Cisco router.
I would love to put in
someone's hands right away.
We're not at that point yet.
So we're working
towards, how do we
get things into the
hands of salespeople
as quickly as possible
when we know that there
are opportunities to do so?
In terms of how does it
improve conversion rate,
we don't have the
specific metrics
around how is conversion rate
improved from before or after.
But one of the things
that we're looking at is--
just general at this point--
anecdotal feedback from sales.
Are they finding value in
what we're providing them?
Is it generally leading to
sort of better outcomes or not?
And so far, the feedback
has been very positive.
So that's been great.
And I'll take the
last one, as well.
MANJU DEVADAS: Sure, go ahead.
SANJIV PATEL: So
the last question
is, how important is accuracy
in the models that you're
developing?
And what are the ways
to increase the accuracy
of the propensity model?
So that's a great question.
And in fact, maybe the
answer might be a little bit
counter-intuitive
in that we are not
overly concerned about accuracy
in the models, at least
initially.
Our goal is to build models
and put them out there
and to learn from them.
And so sometimes a lot of
focus is placed-- especially
when you're involved in
something like Kaggle,
data science competitions--
how do you improve the accuracy
from 74.1 to 74.2?
And that's a huge improvement.
We don't operate in
that kind of mindset.
Our mindset is, let's
build the model.
Let's put it out there.
Let's see how it does.
Is it doing is something that we
think will advance the customer
experience in some way?
And then over time,
iteratively, let's continue
to improve it by
getting more data,
by refining the model itself,
and finding out what works.
That is the fastest
way for us to be
able to make kind of the roadmap
that we talked about a reality.
So that's how I would
answer that question.
MANJU DEVADAS: Great.
Thanks, Sanjiv.
And the last comment from us
is, when you start the journey,
start it in a small way.
Learn, experiment.
Google will help you,
along with Pluto7.
You can conduct a workshop,
build an initial model,
and get started
with the journey.
And from there
on, there is a lot
of learning that comes
into your enterprise.
And have fun.
Thanks, Sanjiv and Vikram.
And with that, stay tuned
for the next session, which
is on from hype to value,
how to start machine learning
projects.
A fun topic, as well.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]